(audience cheering)
All right, let's say hi to Arianna Barry. Hi!
Hi, Arianna!
Hi!
Hi, how are you guys?
Good!
Fantastic!
It's great to be here.
All right.
So what's it gonna be? A Drewth or a dare?
Dare.
Ooh.
A dare. Okay.
Hit us. We're down.
Drew, I dare you to use Ross's phone
to text Ross's fiance, pretending to be him.
Okay.
Wait, what?
I'm like, "I'm in!"
Yes.
Wait, what is she gonna say?
You wanna-
Whatever you want.
Whatever you want, Drew.
I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna do this one.
I'm going to come home tonight,
and I want you to be wearing nothing.
(Ross gasping)
(audience laughing)
(Drew laughing)
And we're gonna howl at the moon.
(audience laughing)
The only problem
with this is that-
I sent it.
You sent it!
(Drew laughing)
(audience applauding)
The only problem with this
is he's gonna know this is not me,
because I have never
texted anything like that.
Oh, my gosh.
Howl at the moon?
(audience laughing)
(Drew laughing)
What did he write back?
Oh, my gosh.
He wrote a crying emoji and a kissy heart mouth.
Oh!
Ooh!
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Whoo! Oh my god, Arianna, that's so fun!
We've never done something like that.
No, I'm texting "That was Drew.
"That was Drew. That was Drew."
I think you should text back.
(Drew howling)
Thank you, Ariana.
You bet!
Thank you!
That was so much,
That was so much fun,
and you're so beautiful.
So is everyone here.
Thank you so much for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you, so,
take it with you!
Take it with you!
(audience cheering)
(bright music)